hey guys it's gonna be a very close race
here as we've mentioned according to the
final CBS News Iowa battleground tracker
former Vice President Joe Biden and
senator Bernie Sanders are tied as
voters first choice with 25% Peabody jej
is close behind followed by senators
Elizabeth Warren and Amy Klobuchar major
Garrett is with me here at the Drake
diner which has become a staple in Iowa
politics after the show right after the
show first we've got to explain to
people what we mean by first choice and
what the heck caucus is anyway right an
Iowa caucus
all caucuses is not a primary people
gather and vote but not on ballots that
would they vote with their feet
literally they gather for a candidate
and then they gather again a second time
before we know who won this happens in
arenas school houses gymnasiums and as
you will see a beautiful quaint little
bar in the middle of farm country grant
Iowa 90 minutes west of Des Moines and
surrounded by corn and cattle fields as
one of Iowa's smallest towns population
90 this year for the first time
grant will hold a Democratic caucus the
venue the hayloft a rustic Bar and Grill
where farm antiques are plentiful and a
hamburger goes for two dollars and 50
cents Zelda Swartz aged 74 has run the
place for 48 years so you know most of
your customers oh yes I'd pretty much
know what most I was going to eat or
drink
when Grant's firehouse declined to host
the caucus the Democratic Party asked
Zelda I'm going to be very honest when
he first called me he didn't say they
were Democrats but that made no
difference to me it may not have made a
difference but there is a difference
there are Democrats and I'm a Republican
you welcome them with open arms you bet
there I've met a lot of them and they're
all very nice people the hayloft will be
one of 1678 caucus sites and Iowa's 99
counties those who attend will align
into candidate preference groups to
qualify for delegates a candidate must
receive at least 15% support at each
site if a candidate doesn't meet that
minimum those supporters can pick
another candidate
this is called realignment Rory price is
the Iowa Democratic party chair
we at the party have been preparing for
record turnout Plus from the very
beginning and so when we started putting
this process together back a year ago we
went to go get the biggest rooms zelda
will host the caucus in the hay lofts
roomy and Knick Knack filled backroom do
you have any idea how many people are
going to show up no I do not concede 125
people more than the whole town right
that's right and although it may be
grants first democratic Iowa caucus the
Democratic Party is trying something new
with voters like this one here in Iowa
and major major here is there a explain
to us exactly what these changes are so
it's about reporting of the data okay
historically the Democratic Party has
just said who won the delegates this
year it's going to say that number but
also who won that first alignment and
then that realignment so there'll be
three numbers tonight it's all about
transparency the Iowa Democratic Party
says but that transparency could be
fought over dogged ly by rival campaigns
and it could if there are number of the
winners both winners and campaigns
fighting over who won and what's the big
winner and who has the momentum
so methinks there might be a complicated
spin factory tomorrow there will be a
spin factory here sufficient to power
every wind turbine in Iowa for the next
six months that is some alternative
energy for you Gale and speaking of
energy I hear the pancakes are terrific
ears we're gonna tuck into some of those
let you keep chewing over politics back
in studio 57 god I love a light fluffy
buttermilk pin the butter and the syrup
that drips over this side lighting this
butter war so let's keep going oh yeah
you're lucky thank you very much Tony to
Coco
you